m
dans le cadre des journées européennes
du patrimoine qui auront lieu les samedi
19 et dimanche 20 septembre 2015
une conférence de presse a eu lieu à la
direction des affaires culturelles de
l'océan indien
ce week-end sera une nouvelle fois
l'occasion de démontrer l'attachement du
conseil départemental à sauvegarder et à
transmettre le patrimoine
d'abord pour nous savons de voix
importantes parce qu'il s'agit
effectivement de faire à nouveau
découvrir pour réunir élus mais aussi
sur le patrimoine
pour nous c'est une démarche purement
identitaire il faut une encre et sonia
important entre ce qui a été dit ce qui
sera demain et quoi de plus important
naturel que de se retrouver de retrouver
des lieux des pratiques des dispositifs
qui rappelle certes pas scéniques
rappelle fondamentalement qui nous
sommes nous aujourd'hui à la réunion
ce que c'est qu'elle a trouvé une vie
vaut rester sur le département
je voudrais tirer
attention sur trois points forts le
premier c'est l'exposition qui aura lieu
sur le musée de villèle et qui croira
d'un grand maître verrier monsieur le
faire le deuxième plus bas c'est notre
connect
faut rappeler qu on a affaire
extrêmement pourtant de vingt mille
images on peut voir et on va aujourd'hui
le voir les voir encore mieux puisqu'on
aura une application ça vous intéresse
vous les jeunes en particulier sur sa
bonne et sur tablette et enfin
belle exposition aussi de costumes
longtemps
avec du département le musée de villèle
profitera donc de cet événement pour
inaugurer son exposition consacrée aux
vitraux de guy lefebvre grand maître
verrier une belle balade à travers
l'ombre et la lumière
alors guy lefebvre effectivement est une
personnalité dans
histoire de fille travaille à la réunion
puisque c'est pratiquement le seul
maître verrier qui oeuvre depuis 50 ans
sur l'île mais pas du survie légalement
madagascar à l'île maurice donc on lui
rend hommage avec cette exposition
exposition rétrospective qui est qui
sera présenté à la fois dans la chapelle
pointue le puisque guy lefebvre en 1985
à orner la chapelle pointue de
magnifiques vitraux art reflets bleus
les violets et la chapelle ne serait
plus ce qu elle s il n'y avait plus les
vitraux demandé de le faire
et puis l'exposition également
présentera le travail du maître derniers
mètres dernier kate ancien artisan à
l'étagé du musée nous seront présentés
des travaux permettant aux visiteurs de
comprendre ce qu'est un vitrail de voir
de vrais vitro et d'avoir un beau
panorama des vitraux réalisés par guy le
faire à partir de prises de vues
magnifiques photographies réalisées par
hervé douris